etienne avec marie louise fort arrive
largement en tête de ce premier tour
mais en cette période troublée par le
coronavirus la maire sortante de sens a
du mal à se réjouir la fois je suis
heureuse parce que c'est même agréable
surtout qu'ils avaient quand même cette
liste qui a une campagne assez difficile
notamment avec le front national et
monsieur odoul particulièrement odieux
parfois mais il n'empêche que
je suis très inquiète du déroulé du
deuxième tour un scrutin marqué par un
fort taux d'abstention
seuls 35% des électeurs sénonais sont
allés voter une abstention qui pour une
fois n'a pas joué en faveur du
rassemblement national julien odoul
termine en troisième position avec
seulement 14 7% des voix quand il ya de
la tension c'est que nos électeurs ne
viennent pas voter notre électorat
encore une fois fait un électorat
populaire qui quelquefois en tout cas
légitimement notamment quand il ya des
crises de cette espèce ne vont ne se
déplace pas à sens c'est une
quadrangulaire qui se dessine le sans
étiquette de laurent moinet et
l'écologiste mathieu bitoun se
qualifient eux aussi pour le second tour
terminer devant le rassemblement
national c'est une satisfaction
symbolique mais forte et autres
satisfactions c'est l'analyse un peu
plus fine des chiffres puisque malgré ce
fort qui même si elle termine en tête à
une vraie érosion de son électorat avec
moins 1600 électeurs dans le pire des
cas on a posé une première pierre et
puis si ce premier tour doit être refait
à cause des circonstances un peu un peu
spécial nous on pense qu'on peut même
faire encore un meilleur score
à sens beaucoup de candidats n'imagine
pas un second tour pour eux ce résultat
risque d'être un simple sondage avant un
report des élections dans des conditions
plus sereines